what are you scared about should I be
scared about well I mean people are
losing their minds right now over the
past 24 hours because of Iran mostly
what you're hearing is you're hearing a
lot of the the the critics of the
current president and apparently there
are some that are saying oh he's you
know he's inching us closer to a
military conflict with Iran well these
are the same brainiacs that said he was
inching us closer to war with North
Korea and they every was completely
wrong on that I'm not saying that
rouhani and the others in the Iranian
regime might not you know decide to
become more bellicose but I think
they're I think they're looking at it
wrong I mean the this idea that because
there's a couple of parts part one is
that they're saying oh look you know he
doesn't have a plan B implying that it's
either this deal which even our European
allies say is inadequate right or it's a
military conflict and that's kind of
what the previous president was was all
about we either get this dealer we're
having a military conflict no there's
other things in the works there's other
options in that in that decision tree
and so I think that's that's a false
premise and the other thing when they
talk about it over the past 24 hours
anyway is is that well look at this is
going to make it harder to get a deal
with with Kim Jong nuttin from North
Korea's cuz he's gonna think that we
don't we don't support our deals well I
look at a different way I think that Kim
jong-un's gonna look at this and think
okay they're not gonna put up with an
inadequate deal right so he's gonna look
at it and say well yeah that because
nobody disagrees with the Iranian deal
they want to talk about they want to
talk about how look the Iranians are
complying with it well the Iranians are
complying with what they agreed to allow
in the deal right which is none of their
military sites the number of times
inspectors have actually gotten on and
inspected a military site including
Parchin the most important military
facility in Iran since that deal was
signed in 2015 was zero haven't been
there because the Iranians didn't agree
to allow any of those sites in this deal
so that's a that's like saying that's
like saying if you're a serial killer
you'll allow the police to come in and
search your home but you can't go in the
basement right not that also a coal does
put their bodies in the basement but I
have you know I suspect that's the case
so anyway that's it's an interesting
thing and I guess I wanted to throw that
out there right off the bat because I
think Iran right now is consuming so
much of the oxygen for people out there
so people thinking that the reason why
we're backing out of the deal is because
the president's being unreasonable and
we're forcing what you're just saying
it's a [ __ ] deal period yeah I think the
idea that we we have to stay in it
because it's better than the alternative
and the alternative you know being war
is is not framing it properly I don't
think that doesn't make any sense to me
but I think that the fact that the UK
the the the French the Germans have all
agreed publicly that it's an inadequate
deal it needs to be fixed that tells you
something but it also tells you that
they have real strong financial
incentives for continuing to do business
in Iran they as to Russia and China
frankly the other signatories so you
know and also here's the other part I
mean Trump you know what is it now we're
16 or 17 months into Trump's
administration so it's not like he got
into the White House and the next day he
you know he can the deal he's been
talking but nobody listens to anything
I'm not a supporter of Trump necessarily
I mean I want the government to work so
it's not that I'm supporting Trump
I support I want the government to work
just like the previous administration I
wasn't a supporter of Obama but hey I
want it to work I want good things to
happen and in also he you know he went
out there and and there was some talk
about let's see if we can't find some
way to get rid of the sunset clause some
way to rein in their ballistic missile
development program something way
although it's not going to happen to
rein in all the the shenanigans if you
want to call it that that they're
engaged in in the Middle East and that
didn't happen so I think he you know
took a step that is not as god-awful as
his critics would like us to believe